So now that we know how to create UI elements, and we know how to animate them,
let's talk about how we can go from that flat UI element on our screen to 3D in-world UI elements.
The widget component is the first step in creating our UI elements in 3D.
Simply put, the widget component manifests 3D UI elements created through UMG into the world.
The widget component itself is a 3D instance of the widget blueprint that you can interact with.
The component offers a great deal of properties that we can leverage as developers.
However, some of the key properties that we should take a look at are space.
This is the coordinate space in which to render the widget.
The choices here would be world or screen.
We've then got the widget class.
This is the class of user widget that will be created and displayed.
From there we've got draw size, which is the size of the displayed quad.
Next we've got window focusable, and this determines whether the virtual window created
to host the widget is focusable by the user.
More specifically, should this take the focus from the user.
And finally we've got the pivot.
This is the pivot point that the widget will use when placed relative to the position of the component.
Having the UI in the world is all well and good, but how do we interact with it?
The widget interaction component has got you covered.
The widget interaction component allows for players to interact with the UI that exists in the 3D game world,
but not on the viewport.
This component is added to the player pawn or the character,
and serves as the physical location for the trace start.
In the example above, we can see that the trace has been fired from the tip of the gun.
In this regard, using the widget interaction component makes dealing with UMG
in immersive virtual reality experiences much more viable.
We can attach an interaction component to each handheld controller.
The actual interaction itself is done by simulating a defined key press.
The component itself can be set up to simulate different types of input methods
such as press, release, or both press and release at the same time
if we wanted to simulate a button click for instance.